Even though it's a trip, once you get there, you're going to live a normal life, and
there's a lot of work
to do.
I haven't
touched anything
at all, so I'm fine
with everything weighing up to 10kg, right?  That means
Weight 42
Allo Don't do your arms twice
[Music]
Surely this might be difficult
I wonder if it's true, it's a
diamond coating It's not
sticky This is a
Japanese-English dictionary I don't need English conversations for travel I'm worried about Chinese conversations for travel
I
'm sure there's something I absolutely need, so I
wonder if it's really Daryl.
It's not written that you should come on board,
so that's the world of
adults.